was just speaking with a woman who is
struggling to lose weight and she feels
like she's doing everything right and
she was telling me how she was gonna go
get a hormone panel done to try to
figure out if there was something else
that she wasn't seeing or wasn't being
addressed so talk to me about the
implications of your hormones being out
of whack hormone hay wires you call it
on weight gain and the inability to shed
pounds we've done a number of research
studies where we've compared various
kinds of diets and the one that seems to
cause the most consistent weight loss
has really two characteristics one is it
avoids the animal products but the other
thing is we do have to keep oils really
low avocados and and nuts they are good
fats but if a person is struggling with
their weight those Foods happen to be
really calorie dense and it's super easy
for your body to absorb it some people
can eat those foods with no difficulty
at all but some others they'll just find
that that their weight loss starts when
those foods are really minimized